o ruim e aí é que esse jornal tudo bom
com o yunus fiwc10 oral de traduzindo
tudo bom com vocês gente gente gente
gente eu cantei gente eu como muitos de
vocês sabem porém está acostuma é bala
como vocês sabem sabem como muitas
pessoas vocês sabem é que a companhia
está no facebook o meu twitter sabe que
eu estou tirando carteira da caximba
apesar de já saber aplicar não é que eu
sou capaz sobre um pouquinho em
pouquinho poquema morreu eu perceber
porquê ayrton senna morreu também também
pouquinho de fora espírito apesar de já
saber dirigir pra você está dentro dos
padrões da lei você tem que tirar sua
carteira para poder transitar
normalmente e aí eu tirei minha carteira
estou impossibilitado de andar em casa
estou andando de que o táxi táxi até um
grande problema verdade está no meu
problema de análise táxi é eu só pego
taxista louco não tem um certo 11
certinho só que um táxi eu pegar se eu
entrasse dentro dele e me deixasse eu
distingo volta o lugar dele eu ficar
mais em kaboul só queria um táxi que me
tratassem bem que minha máxima e 10km
fizesse mulher tá é só brincando eu
tenho uma queixa fazer que toda vez que
eu pego um táxi foi estuprada é sério
toda vez que perguntar às pessoas tudo
pra o que o estoque seja transporte faz
a atividade sexual você não pergunta
como eu só quero eu quero ver quem vai
na padaria na esquina itabom entrei eu
entrei para o ataque deu 45 reais gente
não é roubo e estupro 45 era tudo foi de
táxi estupro postagem não tem um grande
problema em pegar porque assim quando eu
vou pegar táxi eu pego muito lerdo
agora o projeto em que o ele é um táxi
bom dia eu quero ir lá ele fala não
tenho a dizer meu filho você tomar rafa
só um pouquinho não quebra a barreira do
som tem uma vez que o táxi estava tão
rápido rápido eu juro pra você e fez uma
curva conseguir ler a placa na entrada
agora onde você pegar táxi é porque o
taxista ele geralmente ou ele está
dentro tá por ele está fora do táxi
encostar no táxi quer dizer o taxista
não tem muitos amiguinhos então no
centro do táxi ele quer ser seu amigo só
que você não quer ser amigo táxis nome
confessa maior do que a gota série
embora todo bom é que sem deixar nenhum
sobral até que mesmo na nossa aqui não
há beleza mas que mora aqui moro aqui há
beleza massa mas que os pais são daqui
também não meus pais não são daqui que
faz o que tu meu trabalho entender a
treinar como aquele condutor se sabe
como ele é torre de voto a de picles é é
o que mais trabalha carteira assinada é
tudo não quer dizer que o fez e vai
levar o original você vai inscrever no
enem agora um e quando você não pega um
táxi que fala demais você pega um
falando nada e esse é o que eu também
faço vai pra onde
sobral é pedreira
eu tenho medo que eu acho que qualquer
um mesmo falei que vou me espantar teve
uma vez que eu peguei o time mais longo
da minha vida fui pra você eu fui
assistir um show e do estado paulo
estava em acabou chuva menu e quase não
passava de táxi mas quando parou tarô
táxi parou o táxi estava à porta o cinto
caiu no chão no carro onde estava
tocando garota [ __ ] no volume 40 do
sul fronteiriça que vai capotar com
certeza era uma cela num passado mais
forma o meu deus menino tão bom ele
passava a marcha no viaduto novo me
naquele dia fiquei cultura que não
passava motorola time da maior estrutura
é taxista que entrega o cartão porque eu
amo muito detalhados logo eu recebi
muito cartão gente eu tenho um
cartãozinho aqui para um canavial gente
é isso tanto cartão digitar se tocar
fazendo o barril eu invoco o é de carros
o seu é de carro novo vai ser paga para
o meu clown 10 vaninho eu coloco é de
1.100 modo de defesa eu tenho um capital
que tem vocal exógenos taxista recebeu
no domingo pega o stoke city pela
galinha mas se você tiver gostar desse
vídeo que você clique gostei aqui no
youtube você vai incidir no facebook eu
quero que você volte no facebook clique
em curtir para que mais gente veja o
vídeo e se inscreve no canal no youtube
pra você nunca peguei mais visitar benê
é nas redes sociais de que a descrição
do vídeo que quiser seguir isto está no
instagram e no facebook valeu e na sky e